notre réunion de commission je vous
informe que contenu de l'audition
ministre la Justice garde des sceaux il
y a une retransmission par le site
internet du Sénat de cette audition
je garde des sceaux merci de votre
présence d'abord
la France fait partie des pays européens
qui ont vu partir le plus de jeunes
hommes et femmes pour combattre en Irak
et en Syrie aux côtés de l'organisation
islamiste daesh
on parle de plus de 1400 personnes ayant
fait un séjour dans cette zone entre
2012 et la chute de l'organisation
terroriste en 2019
trois ans plus tard le nombre de
français détenus dans le nord de la
Syrie est encore de plusieurs centaines
sans que nous disposions de chiffres
exacts
parmi eux des enfants sont détenus avec
ou même sans leurs parents là encore les
chiffres exacts nous font défaut mais
sans doute peut-être vous allez pouvoir
nous en communiquer en tous les cas de
ce que vous disposez
notre pays a toujours refusé le principe
d'un retour général de tous les détenus
français mais à procédé au cas par cas à
des rapatriements de femmes et d'enfants
notamment au mois de juillet dernier et
encore lundi dernier
à ce jour les décisions de la France en
matière sont des actes de gouvernement
au sens du droit public et donc un
susceptible de recours devant les juges
nationaux
saisi par des familles des personnes
ayant demandé son succès leur
rapatriement pardon la Cour européenne
des droits de l'homme a rendu le 14
septembre dernier un arrêt confortant la
position française d'examens au cas par
cas
mais parce qu'il y a un mais la Cour
exige que les décisions prises par le
gouvernement puissent faire l'objet d'un
contrôle indépendant pour prévenir tout
arbitraire et garantir la prise en
compte notamment de l'intérêt supérieur
de l'enfant
les décisions de refus de rapatriement
prise jusqu'à présent et que l'on donc
été sans quantités qui étaient donc
pardon sans ce contrôle qui n'existe pas
pour le moment doivent en conséquence de
cette joys prudence peut-être être
examiné
chez le ministre nous souhaitons bien
sûr vous entendre sur deux points
principaux le premier quel est l'ampleur
de la situation à laquelle nous devons
faire face aujourd'hui combien de
Français est parmi eux combien d'enfants
peuvent demander leur rapatriement sur
le territoire national depuis le nord de
la Syrie
quelle sera la doctrine du gouvernement
la matière singulièrement à l'égard de
ses enfants
et enfin au vu la jurisprudence de la
cdH qui pourrait conduire à des
rapatriements peut-être plus nombreux
dans les prochains mois d'ailleurs
comment faire face à cette situation
voilà deux pistes monsieur le ministre
naturellement j'imagine bien que les
collègues ici par exemple au sont des
questions mais je vous laisse
immédiatement la parole merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président de la commission des lois
mais c'est notre triche messieurs les
sénateurs vous avez souhaité m'entendre
sur
je vous en prie sur l'épineuse question
des des combattants et combattants
revenus des zones de guerre en Syrie en
Irak et de leurs enfants
je tiens à vous en remercier car c'est
effectivement un sujet complexe
qui justifie la pleine mobilisation du
gouvernement et du Parlement
car vous le savez il interroge nos
valeurs
notre humanité en posant la foi des
enjeux absolument considérables pour
notre sécurité et pour celle de nos de
nos concitoyens
durant presque 5 ans
daesh
a étendu son emprise en Irak et en Syrie
sur un territoire de la taille
proche de celui de la Grande-Bretagne
la barbarie la plus féroce
portée par l'idéologie islamiste
c'est abattu sur ces régions et sur ses
habitants
nous avons tous été témoins des horreurs
qui se sont succédés
des capitations exécution massives
rap violent masse destruction massive de
sites historiques
tout cela portait par une propagande
terrifiante spécialement conçue pour
s'adresser à la jeunesse occidentale
malheureusement t'attirer de nombreux
combattants en terroristes femmes et
hommes et en ce qui concerne la France
le nombre de nos ressortissants ayant
rejoint les rangs de daesh et estimé je
dis bien estimé à 1500
beaucoup ont reçu un entraînement pour
mener une guerre ainsi qu'un un
endoctrinement pour porter par une
idéologie
islamiste et vous le savez notre pays a
subi ce terrorisme dans sa chair notre
pays a fait partie des cibles je le dis
bien sûr avec gravité car il fait hélas
toujours partie des cibles
aujourd'hui nombre de ces combattants
ont été tués notamment dans les combats
en Irak et en Syrie lorsqu'il a été mis
fin à daech d'autres ont été arrêtés et
condamnés en Irak d'autres sont retenus
dans les camps du Nord du Nord-Est
syrien sous contrôle kurde d'autres ont
fins sont rentrés volontairement ont été
expulsés par les autorités turques dans
le cadre de ce que nous avons appelé le
protocole Cazeneuve
tous les hommes et toutes les femmes qui
sont rentrés ont fait l'objet de
poursuite pénale systématique en France
la capacité de projection opérationnelle
de daesh c'est aujourd'hui
considérablement réduite mais la menace
liée au retour de cette djihadistes en
Europe demeurent réelle les combattants
terroristes encore sur zone font bien
sûr l'objet d'un suivi attentif il en
est évidemment de même des revenants
incarcérés ou remises en liberté les
services de renseignement et les
autorités judiciaires en charge de la
lutte contre le terrorisme sont bien sûr
mobilisés sur ces enjeux majeurs pour
notre sécurité c'est simple dès que le
parquet national antiterroriste a
connaissance du départ ou du maintien
sur jaune de ressortissants français
postérieurement aux attentats de janvier
2015 il ouvre systématiquement une
procédure du chef d'association de
malfaiteurs
en lien avec une entreprise terroriste
notre politique pénale ne distingue pas
entre les hommes et les femmes sauf à
démontrer l'existence d'un élément de
contrainte les femmes partis sur jaune
sont traitées comme les hommes contenus
de leur niveau dans doctrinement et de
la place qui était souvent conféré qu'il
aurait été conféré au sein des
cette exactement ce qui s'est passé en
juillet dernier lors du retour de 16
femmes accompagné de leurs enfants
toutes toutes ont été mises en examen et
incarcéré
quel est le suivi de revenant pendant la
détention fin septembre 129 revenant de
zones Irak au syriennes dont 51 femmes
sont incarcérées dans les établissements
susceptibles d'accueillir les publics
terroristes islamistes femmes les 10
les femmes comme les hommes ont vocation
à entrer dans le dispositif de prise en
charge de la radicalisation
celui-ci comme vous le savez repose sur
des phases successives d'évaluation et
de prise en charge de la radicalisation
dans des quartiers spécialisés par des
équipes spécialement formées
notamment si un risque de prosélytisme
voire de passage à l'acte violent est
identifié
la situation de chaque détenu fait
l'objet d'un réexamen régulier notamment
pour adapter les mesures de sécurité et
le renseignement pénitentiaire
est également et logiquement mobilisé
alors sortie la loi du 30 juillet 2021 a
comblé comme vous le savez un vide en
permettant de poursuivre la prise en
charge et le suivi à l'issue de la
détention en sus des éventuels mesures
administratives
s'agissant de la prise en charge des
enfants la situation est bien sûr
différente
contrairement à leurs parents les
enfants n'ont pas fait le choix de
rejoindre daesh et notre responsabilité
à notre à leur égard et de concilier
humanité d'abord car contrairement à
leurs parents ils ont pas choisi de
devenir terroriste
et aussi une grande prudence et un grand
pragmatisme car ses enfants
considérés par la propagande islamiste
comme je cite les lions sauts du califat
sont aussi des enjeux d'influence pour
daesh qui les a souvent endoctrinés dès
le plus jeune âge et ils ont tous
absolument tous vécus des expériences
traumatisantes
leur récit
qui parfois
ne se libère que quelques années après
leur retour
font à vrai dire froid dans le dos
quelques chiffres de nouveaux pour être
très concrets c'est une de vos demandes
monsieur le président
la France accueille 225 mineurs
ayant séjourné dans une zone d'opération
des groupes terroristes
parmi eux 217 en séjourné en zone Irak
au syrienne et 8 autres enfants dans
d'autres jeunes de conflits Afghanistan
Libye
la plupart de ces enfants
sont rentrés avec leurs parents soit
parce que ceux-ci ont été expulsés
notamment de Turquie soit parce qu'ils
sont rentrés spontanément sur le
territoire national par ailleurs
77 mineurs ont été rapatriés par les
autorités françaises
dont 71 depuis les camps de rojava en 7
opérations successives et cela entre le
15 mars 2019 et le 4 octobre 2022 et 6
autres depuis l'Irak
comme vous le savez une opération de
rapatriement a été
mené le 5 juillet 2022
permettant le retour de 35 mineurs et de
16 femmes
il s'agissait de la sixième opération
menée par la France pour permettre le
retour de ses enfants
cette fois-ci avec leur mère une autre
opération très ponctuelle a eu lieu hier
pour amener un enfant de 6 ans en
situation médicale critique ainsi que sa
mère et son frère de 8 ans l'enfant a
été hospitalisé la mère placée en
détention provisoires d'autres
opérations pourront suivre lorsque les
familles sont volontaires pour rentrer
je vous aborder la question
suivante comment comment ces mineurs
sont suivis sur les 225 mineurs de
retour de jaunes
218 ont fait l'objet d'une procédure en
assistance éducative
188 mesures sont aujourd'hui en cours
11 d'entre eux ont fait l'objet de
poursuite pénale du chef d'association
de malfaiteurs terroristes
leur âge évidemment a été pris en compte
et ils sont aujourd'hui majeurs
ces chiffres permettent de prendre la
mesure du problème d'appréhender la
qualité de la réponse judiciaire que
nous formulons
c'est en effet avec une extrême
attention et une totale mobilisation que
le gouvernement traite ce sujet
difficile
concernant les mineurs rapatriés par la
France
un dispositif désormais rodé s'est mis
en place sous la
coordination
du parquet national antiterroriste il
articule un dispositif national de suivi
et des mesures individuelles pour chacun
de ces mineurs
le dispositif national a été reprécisé
par une instruction
interministérielle du 21 avril 2022 qui
précise le circuit de prise en charge
des mineurs à travers une répartition
déconcentrée sur l'ensemble du
territoire suivant les liens familiaux
de saison
dans les jours qui viennent je vais
signer une circulaire de mise en oeuvre
spécifique de cette instruction dans le
domaine judiciaire mais déjà les
dispositions de suivi renforcées
préconisés par l'instruction ont été
mises en oeuvre à l'occasion des retours
du mois de juillet dernier dans chaque
département
accueillant l'un de ces mineurs un suivi
doit s'organiser au sein des cellules
départementales de prévention de la
radicalisation et d'accompagnement des
familles qui se réunit pour l'occasion
en formation restreinte sous la double
responsabilité des procureurs de la
République et des préfets
les réunions
de ces cellules départementales de
prévention
font l'objet de remonter systématique
d'information au parquet national
antiterroriste
un comité interministériel de suivi se
réunit à échéance régulière pour évaluer
le fonctionnement du dispositif je vais
vous dire qu'il s'est d'ailleurs réuni
aujourd'hui même
sur le plan individuel tous les mineurs
arrivés sur le territoire national font
l'objet d'une prise en charge judiciaire
là aussi systématique cette prise en
charge judiciaire cumule un placement
à l'aide sociale à l'enfance du
département et une mesure éducative en
milieu ouvert une interdiction de sortie
du territoire est aussi systématiquement
requise
cette prise en charge débute dès la
descente de l'avion pour les mineurs
rapatriés des zones de groupements
terroristes comme je l'ai dit après une
première évaluation notamment sur les
aspects médicaux
ils sont placés sur des sillons du
procureur de la République dans des
familles ou des structures d'accueil
adaptées et rapidement rapprocher des
lieux dans lesquels ils ont des liens
familiaux quand ils en ont encore sont
alors les parquets locaux qui sont
saisis
lorsque leur mère sont incarcérées des
parloirs médiatisés sont organisés afin
d'assurer le maintien des liens
familiaux entre les enfants et leur mère
il s'agit souvent d'enfants très jeunes
les deux tiers ont moins de 10 ans et 22
de ses enfants sont orphelins
77 d'entre eux sont nés sur jaune et
n'ont jamais connu la France
ils arrivent sur notre territoire
national sans état civil et sans lien de
filiation établie cet aspect bien sûr
est également pris en compte
vous l'imaginez aisément de suivi de ses
enfants est un travail au long cours
et lorsque c'est possible ceci également
les familles mais
souvent
souvent les grands-parents
immobilisent tous les acteurs qui
entourent ces enfants éducateurs
magistrats soignants psychiatre
psychologue enseignant qui ont vocation
assurer une articulation entre le suivi
administratif et l'indispensable suivi
judiciaire
il faut permettre à ses enfants de
retrouver précisément une enfance
aussi normale que que possible et ce
sans bien sûr relâcher notre vigilance
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
l'attitude de la France concernant la
situation des ressortissants retenus
dans le reste syrien a été souvent
fustigé devant différentes instances
internationales le Comité des droits de
l'enfant ou le Comité contre la torture
de l'ONU
je veux ici vous dire que la position de
la France est en réalité parfaitement
équilibrée
elle tient compte notamment du nombre de
Français concernés
puisque la France fait partie des pays
ayant le plus grand nombre de
combattants terroristes étrangers
elle poursuit comme je l'ai dit un
objectif qui est de concilier humanité à
l'égard en particulier des enfants et
responsabilités au regard de notre
sécurité collective qu'il nous incombe
d'assurer à cet égard l'arrêt de la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme du 14
septembre dernier ne remet pas en cause
cet équilibre
comme le soutenait le gouvernement la
Cour considère
que la France ne peut pas être tenu pour
responsable des conditions de vie dans
les camps du nord-est de la Syrie
puisqu'elle n'y exerce
absolument pas sa juridiction
c'est du bon sens et c'est surtout la
stricte et triste réalité
la Cour confirme également que les
engagements internationaux de la France
en matière de protection des droits de
l'homme
n'impose pas à celle-ci de procéder au
rapatriement des personnes retenues dans
le nord-est syrien ces deux points
sont absolument fondamentaux
certes la France est condamnée mais
seulement pour n'avoir pas formalisé ni
objectiver le processus décisionnel
conduisante au non rapatriement
le gouvernement examine comment donner
suite à cet arrêt afin de s'y conformer
mais comme je l'ai déjà dit nous n'avons
pas attendu cette arrêt pour agir et 77
enfants sont déjà rentrés et prises en
charge
d'autres retours sont possibles mais il
dépendent directement des conditions de
sécurité sur place
j'entends sur ces questions tellement de
fausses experts
qui nous débite à longueur de propos des
Yaka faucon faudrait les choses sont
difficiles
en cause évidemment la sécurité des
différents intervenants nos soldats bien
sûr
des
déchirements internes parce que la femme
qui accepte de livrer son enfant et
elle-même victime des autres femmes qui
sont restées là puisqu'elle est
considérée comme collabo
donc entre les redomontas que l'on peut
lire dans certaines gazettes et la
réalité de terrain il y a une nuance
évidemment qui ne peut pas échapper
au sénateur que vous êtes
j'ajoute que
des évasions déjà eu lieu
que daesh pourraient essayer de
récupérer des combattants terroristes en
tant que la région est particulièrement
instable et que l'autorité des forces
Kurdes qui tiennent les camps s'inscrit
je vais le dire comme ça dans un cadre
géopolitique d'une très très grande
complexité
et pour organiser les opérations de
retour lorsque c'est possible
toujours très compliqué
très complexe très difficile
et c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous sommes comme vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur le Président d'une part au cas
par cas
et que
deuxièmement il ne suffit pas de claquer
des doigts et d'affirmer un certain
nombre de choses pour qu'elle se réalise
chaque fois que ces retours ont lieu je
le dis très clairement la France doit
assurer une réponse de fermeté pour les
adultes
dans la réaffirmation bien sûr de nos
règles et de l'État de droit et c'est ce
qui nous différencie évidemment de la
barbarie de daesh
je veux d'ailleurs ici saluer le bon
déroulement du procès des terribles
attentats du 13 novembre c'est une
véritable réussite
en juger seulement par le fait que
personne n'a interjeté appel et que donc
tout le monde c'est satisfait de la
décision je veux naturellement avant de
de terminer mon mon propos liminaire et
de répondre à vos questions merci ici
tous les acteurs magistrats avocats
associations de victimes greffiers
forces de l'ordre qui ont permis que ce
procès historique fasse pleinement toner
à notre pays à notre État de droit et je
veux enfin avoir une pensée appuyée pour
les victimes de l'horrible attentat de
Nice
dont le procès se déroule actuellement
la France doit faire en sorte de
réintégrer ses enfants dans notre
collectivité nationale
vigilance humanité
l'un ne peut en la matière laissant
l'autre assurer cette difficile mission
et l'honneur de notre République de mon
ministère dans son champ de compétence
et nous sommes pleinement mobilisés pour
y répondre voilà monsieur le Président
rapidement brosser
la première intervention qui merci
monsieur le ministre pour l'ensemble de
ces éléments
j'ai plusieurs demandes de paroles le
premier d'entre nous et Monsieur Denis
puis ensuite Monsieur Alain Marc
merci Monsieur gardetteaux pour vos
précisions j'avais trois questions à
vous poser bon les conditions de retour
de de ces personnes
autodides moi j'ai répondu bien sûr les
poursuites pénales il y avait répondu et
les moyens de réinsertion moi je
voudrais parler plus précisément du
délai de jugement quand ces personnes
vont rentrer entre le temps de revenir
sur sur le sol et le délai de jugement
parce que ce temps-là est important pour
savoir bien sûr à qui on a affaire si
c'est très radicalisé ou
par Handicap légèrement réglé radicalisé
et surtout les différentes étapes en
fonction de l'état de la personne s'il y
a un gros travail de fond à faire ou si
on peut récupérer facilement et au
niveau des enfants également dire ça va
pas être simple
parce que bon je sais pas combien il
faut être personne par enfant mais si on
a senti des enfants je suppose que c'est
presque aucun cas par cas avez-vous les
moyens
financiers et la question
aurons-nous un retour d'étape si on peut
parler comme ça dans un an pour reparler
un peu du sujet parce que je pense qu'il
y aura plusieurs vagues là on est au 1er
départ et si on arrive à totalité il
faut peut-être plus de monde qu'on a du
jeu de personnes à justice
merci Monsieur Lamarck puis ensuite il y
a la maryse Carrère merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre je
voudrais savoir si nous établissements
pénitentiaires sont dimensionnés pour
recevoir des femmes c'est-à-dire
radicalisées vous avez dit ça nous a
juste titre qu'il fallait que c'est le
si soit proche de leurs enfants les
enfants eux-mêmes étant proche de leur
famille lorsqu'il y en avait donc
j'imagine que elles sont un petit peu
disséminées sur sur le territoire mais
quand même temps il faut concevoir un
programme de d'éradicalisation pour ces
mères mais aussi pour ces mineurs qui
sont endoctrinées et moi j'aimerais
savoir en quoi consiste ce programme de
déradicalisation
merci Madame carraire puis madame
mustache brignot
président monsieur le ministre j'aurais
deux questions et ma première question
concernera la protection judiciaire de
la jeunesse en vue du projet de loi de
finances futures la question de la
situation des enfants actuellement
détenus avec leur mère et rapatriés de
Syrie est appelé à se poser avec plus
d'acuités les services de protection de
l'enfance et la protection judiciaire de
la jeunesse spécialement à Nîmes de
France car ses enfants arrivent dans les
aéroports de la région parisienne on
définit des modalités de prise en charge
spécifique pour ces mineurs ces
modalités de prise en charge sont-elles
appelées à évoluer et les moyens
sont-ils suffisants et adaptés à
l'accueil de ces mineurs ma deuxième
question concernera des cas peut-être
plus rares et vous avez rappelé les
procédures au cas par cas et j'espère
qu'il concerneront aussi les enfants qui
ont été amenés par leurs parents sans
avoir le choix dans ces camps et qui ont
depuis Athènes la majorité et qui sont
souvent malheureusement orphelins et
dans les familles attendent impatiemment
un dénouement pour récupérer ces jeunes
ces jeunes adultes c'est malheureusement
nous sommes tous nous connaît nous
connaissons tous des situations
dramatiques dans nos territoires c'est
le cas dans les Hautes-Pyrénées dans les
Hautes-Pyrénées ou la famille Riou
attend avec impatience et espère voir
revenir leur nièce et petites filles
Amina qui est aujourd'hui enfermé dans
un camp en Syrie contre sa volonté et
qui est malheureusement passé sa
majorité je vous remercie merci Madame
stage brignot puis ensuite monsieur
Stéphane Le rugulier merci monsieur le
Président d'abord vous me permettrez
d'avoir une pensée pour
les centaines de morts voilà liées aux
attentats il y ait surtout à cette
idéologie mortifère et barbare et qui
sont tombés en France et vous me
permettrez quand même de rappeler et je
sais à Monsieur le Ministre que la
géopolitique est compliquée je sais que
ce sujet compliqué mais je voudrais
quand même qu'on n'oublie pas que celles
et ceux qui veulent rentrer chez nous
ont applaudit ces attentats moi je
voulais le dire c'est important pour moi
parce que nous avons tous été concernés
par ces attentats de près ou de loin et
on ne peut pas les oublier et la France
ne veut pas les oublier mais j'admet
monsieur le ministre que rien n'est
simple dans le contexte actuel moi je
voudrais alors peut-être l'avez-vous dit
et peut-être n'est-je pas bien entendu
je voudrais savoir combien sur zone il y
a encore d'enfants à rapatrier je ne
sais pas si vous l'avez précisé est-ce
qu'on sait combien d'enfants devaient
être rapatriés moi je voudrais avoir le
chiffre précis d'enfants qui sont
revenus sans leur mère c'est-à-dire
est-ce que combien d'enfants sont
revenus avec les maires qui sont restés
sur zone donc ça veut dire qu'il est
possible de rapatrier les enfants sans
leur mère je pense que ça c'est
important qu'on puisse connaître ce
chiffre alors évidemment la prise en
charge des enfants on connaît le
contexte on sait que c'est pas simple on
que chaque histoire est une histoire
individuelle qui n'est pas comme celle
du voisin parce que ses enfants ont
effectivement vécu l'horreur et je
voudrais aussi avoir une information
monsieur ministre sur ces femmes en
particulier qui sont revenues qui sont
parfois encore plus dangereuses que
certains hommes est-ce que parmi celles
qui sont rentrés il y en a déjà qui sont
ressortis qui ont été incarcérées plus
ou moins longtemps et qui sont déjà
ressortis et si oui quel est le suivi de
ces femmes dans leur vie au quotidien
est-ce qu'il y a un suivi oui ou non et
est-ce que c'est prévu
si Monsieur le résulier puis monsieur
Richard merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre je vous ai écouté
avec attention et vous avez pris des
précautions en termes de vocabulaire
puisque vous n'avez pas de mémoire
employé le mot rapatriement ce qui est
très bien puisque cela veut dire que
nous n'avons pas de dette morale en tout
cas pour les personnes adultes les
femmes qui ont commis et qui ont violé
toutes les valeurs qui ont fait
l'identité de la France et plus
largement le monde occidental mais
au-delà de cette précision sémantique il
y a une véritable question de fond c'est
quels sont les conséquences
qu'entraînent le retour de ces femmes
notamment en détention puisque vous
allez me détromper mais de ce que je
sais c'est que ces femmes sont dans une
prison en détention classique et que
elles ne sont pas ces prisons ne sont
pas adaptées pour l'heure à accueillir
ces femmes
et donc il y a véritablement et vous
l'avez dit dans votre propos un risque
d'influence d'endoctrinement de
prosélytisme dans le milieu carcéral et
si on le se réfère un peu à nos pays
voisins on voit que le Royaume-Uni a
retiré la nationalité et interdit le
retour de plus de 150 jadis le Danemark
est sur la même
trajectoire
en clair n'est-il pas tant pour nous
qu'on fasse de même et qu'on s'interroge
sur cette fameuse déchéance de
nationalité de ces personnes doit-on
considérer ces femmes djihadistes comme
des Français
ce serait peut-être l'occasion aussi
d'envoyer un message assez fort et assez
clair à nos concitoyens et au reste du
monde en France il n'y a aucune place de
quelques natures que ce soit pour ceux
qui violent nos valeurs n'est-il pas
plus juste en clair qu'elle soit jugée
dans le pays où elles ont
ces actes terroristes et bien évidemment
seuls les enfants méritent d'être
rapatriés au nom de leurs propres
intérêt merci Monsieur laudulier
monsieur André Richard puis monsieur
bonne Carrère merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre merci
pour vos informations
j'aurais souhaité vous poser deux
questions complémentaires en lien avec
les chiffres que vous nous avez déjà
indiqués
la première question qui va d'ailleurs
endroit de ligne de celle de Jacqueline
stage brignot
est-ce que est-ce que vous vous avez une
idée du nombre de ressortissants
français qui reste encore détenu sur
zone alors bien entendu enfants c'est la
question de Jacqueline mais bien sûr
aussi de combattants de combattants
ma question tout de suite incidente la
deuxième question
la question tout de suite incidente
c'est
que faire de ces gens et donc plus
précisément
comment la France
qui n'est pas contrainte en vertu de la
Cour européenne de la décision de la
Cour européenne n'est pas contrainte de
les rapatrier que veut faire le
gouvernement à l'égard de ces personnes
qui sont encore détenues sur zone est-ce
que vous vous envisagez de faire un
choix un tri un cas par cas sur la base
de quels critères le cas échéant ou
est-ce que à terme le gouvernement
visage un rapatriement total et ma
question tout de suite incidente et la
suivante est-ce que les personnes qui se
trouvent à l'heure actuelle
rapatriés entre guillemets en France et
détenus
ont-elles toutes fait une demande à cet
égard est-ce que c'est toujours sur
demande des gens concernés il n'y a pas
par exemple dans le protocole Cazeneuve
il n'y a jamais eu d'obligation pour des
gens de rentrer livrés par exemple par
la Turquie c'est une demande une demande
à chaque fois donc si demande il y a je
répète ma question y a-t-il un choix des
autorités françaises à l'égard de telle
ou telle personne selon qu'elle aurait
plus participé qu'elle aurait pour être
clair plus de 100 sur sur les mains et
enfin
nous avons eu la commission des lois eu
l'occasion d'aller visiter Rennes et
notamment de constater les efforts qui
étaient faits par le gouvernement
français tout particulièrement en ce qui
concerne la
déradécalisation des femmes même
question que que posée par une collecte
tout à l'heure compte tenu du nombre de
personnes qui restent encore détenues
sur zone est-ce que la France a des
capacités à la fois de recevoir ces gens
mais à multiplier le cas échéant
l'expérience de Rennes
oui merci monsieur le garde des sceaux
pour ces observations sur un sujet que
l'on sait délicat et sur lequel
l'humilité particulièrement de rigueur
je voudrais éviter les anecdotes mais
ayant été comme beaucoup d'entre vous
mère je garde quand même le souvenir
douloureux de n'avoir su que bien après
que cinq jeunes el bijoux étaient partis
au jihad et cela m'avait permis de me
rendre compte que je ne savais pas aussi
bien que je l'avais imaginé ce qui se
passait dans la ville que je gérais donc
beaucoup d'humilité deux questions la
première concernant le suivi des mineurs
pour les les mers je pense que vous avez
des dispositifs juridiques tout à fait
suffisant les incriminations en matière
de terrorisme préparatoire
d'associations etc sont suffisamment
largement d'avis pour assurer la
couverture et derrière vous avez comme
vous l'avez rappeler avec 2021 les
mesures administratives de type Mikas
sur les mineurs je vois mal quelle
peut-être la compétence du pnaté vous
avez évoqué des cellules départementales
j'entendrai vous opérations
départementales je pense que l'objectif
des parlementaires c'est d'avoir la
certitude que ces mineurs feront
effectivement l'objet d'un suivi très
précis le monde
des AEMO etc fait que c'est le les
départements qui en pratique prennent la
main là-dessus donc est-ce que les
départements sont avertis un petit peu
du parcours de de ses enfants et en
résumé est-ce que vous pouvez nous
garantir de la capacité de notre pays
à suivre dans la durée là dans la mesure
où la majorité de ces enfants ont moins
de 10 ans l'enjeu c'est d'avoir une
visibilité pour la dizaine d'année qui
qui vient comment vous le centraliser
comment vous l’organiser deuxième
question le la CEDH effectivement
n'oblige pas un rapatriement elle
prévoit simplement que la décision doit
être pris soit par un juge soit par une
autorité indépendante on voit pas très
bien laquelle et qu'il y est une
modalité de recours est-ce que vous avez
défini puisque je n'ai aucune aucun
doute sur le fait que il va y avoir des
recours dans les mois qui dans les mois
et qui viennent est-ce que vous avez
défini une procédure pour savoir qui
prend la décision positive et négative
et quelle est la modalité de recours et
par j'avais presque jusqu'à dire est-ce
que vous avez ou non besoin d'un
véhicule législatif là-dessus ou vos
dispositifs réglementaires vous
permettent de mettre en place cette
méthodologie de traitement des recours
merci et bonne Carrère donc Monsieur
Jean-Pierre Sueur et ensuite ce sera
monsieur Loïc Hervé
sur le Président je voulais comme
d'autres collègues vous demandez
monsieur le ministre si vous pouviez
nous dire combien de femmes et d'enfants
restent dans ces camps
oui reste dans ses camps combien de
femmes
ont refusé le retour
et donc combien reste-t-il de femmes qui
n'ont pas refusé le retour et d'enfants
et est-ce que vous comptez donc
multiplier les opérations jusqu'à ce que
on puisse organiser le retour de toutes
les personnes qui en expriment la
volonté et des enfants bien sûr j'ai une
deuxième question qui prolonge celle de
Monsieur va te blé par rapport à la
déradicalisation
nous avons fait dans la Commission des
études déjà par le passé et moi je suis
très critique sur un certain nombre
d'officines auxquels on a fait appel
pour organiser la déradicalisation avec
des dispositifs très sommaires qui
consiste à laisser penser que dès qu'on
a reçu une vidéo après une deuxième
vidéo
un enseignement une troisième vidéo
voilà on est d'éradicalisé c'est
complètement illusoire vous comprenez
quand vous pensez quelque chose dans
votre tête que vous avez une conviction
intime
c'est compliqué d'arriver à ce que vous
vous en détachiez et à ce que vous
pensiez le contraire donc en fait c'est
un processus très difficile
qui demande sans doute le concours de
personnes ayant des capacités en
psychologie voire plus
très très élaboré et qui prend du temps
donc je voulais vous demander quelle est
la nature de cette déradicalisation à la
fois au sein des établissements
pénitentiaires et en dehors
merci Monsieur Hervé puis madame
belleritti merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre j'avais des
questions de deux ordres d'abord que
vous convient peut-être sur une
dimension qui a pas été abordé jusqu'à
maintenant que la question de la
dimension européenne comment est-ce que
cette même situation est gérée par nos
voisins européens notamment par les
Anglais
ça pourrait peut-être nous inspirer nous
intéresser de voir comment les Anglais
les Allemands les Italiens
les pays de l'Est de l'Europe gèrent ces
situations là parce qu'ils ont connu
aussi des départs au djihad et j'imagine
qu'ils ont eux-mêmes des stratégies
comme je ne remets pas en cause la
dimension nationale de la stratégie mais
je me dis qu'il doit y avoir peut-être
d'autres manières de gérer la chose
et avons-nous une politique de
coopération européenne en la matière
et ma deuxième question c'est la
question du droit des droits des
grands-parents j'ai vu quelques
émissions sur le sujet
de grands-parents qui ont des
petits-enfants qui ne connaissent pas et
qu'est-ce qu'il y a des dispositifs
spécifiques qui sont mis en oeuvre pour
préserver leurs droits vis-à-vis de ses
enfants et à l'égard aussi des enfants
en question bien évidemment merci
beaucoup si Monsieur Hervé madame
belriti puis ensuite madame l'herbier
le ministre les demandes de repatriement
de ressortissants français depuis
l'étranger sont jusqu'à ce jour
considérés comme ircevable par le
Conseil d'État qui voit des actes de
gouvernement totalement injusticiables
or le 14 septembre dernier la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme a
condamné la France dans une affaire
relative à des rapatriements depuis la
Syrie affirmant que ces demandes
devraient être examinées par une
juridiction française et que les motifs
de la décision de non rapatriement
devait au moins faire l'objet d'un
contrôle minimum quelle évolution
juridique prudentielle faut-il attendre
selon vous du Conseil d'État compte tenu
de cette décision
merci ma belle Richie madame l'herbier
puis monsieur tanimavet de soli oui
monsieur le ministre moi j'aimerais
savoir comment on va
[Musique]
si ce n'est formé mais tout au moins
aider les juges chargés de ses enfants
les juges des enfants sont
particulièrement attentifs l'aspect
psychologique etc certes ils ont été
formés en amont pour ce genre de
problème mais là on est quand même dans
une dimension
extraordinaire vont-ils avoir une
formation surplus vu le nombre d'enfants
il va y avoir un nombre de magistrats
très important chargé de ce suivi est-ce
qu'au fur et à mesure de l'évolution de
de ce qu'on constate on va adapter
une formation quelconque assez assez
magistrats et ma deuxième question si
vous voulez bien monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre
concerne la prise en charge de ces
enfants on a parlé tout à l'heure de
d'aide sociale à l'enfance est-ce qu'il
y a un risque
que l'on puisse un jour ou l'autre avoir
des enfants de ce style placés avec des
des enfants de droit commun chez les
assistantes familiales qui ne seraient
pas forcément très formé non plus pour
gérer tout ça que ça soit de chez les
assistants de familiales on les foyers
ou autres comment on va gérer la
confrontation entre ces deux mondes
sachant que les enfants de l'Aide
Sociale à l'enfant sont déjà des enfants
fragiles et qu'il ne faut pas en
rajouter encore plus dans leur situation
merci madame monsieur Tani m'avez suali
puis madame Marie Mercier monsieur le
Président ma question
ma question a été posée par Loïc Hervé
qui consistait à demander ce que ce que
faisait les
les pays où règnent un état de droit que
ce soit en Europe ou dans le monde la
France et le pays le plus concerné sur
le garde des sceaux la préciser mais
est-ce que d'autres pays
démocratiques sont concernés et quel
traitement réserve-t-il à cette
situation
merci merci beaucoup monsieur le
président monsieur le garde des sceaux
mes chers collègues nous sommes donc
allés à la prison des femmes de Rennes
je peux vous dire que ce sont des
visites extrêmement marquantes ce sont
des quartiers très sécurisés ce sont des
femmes donc les détenus ne se croisent
pas elles restent dans leur quartier
extrêmement fermé j'ai bien regardé le
nom sur les cellules il y avait un nom
bien breton et il y avait des noms qui
ne l'était pas en fait toute la
difficulté c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
profil type de ces femmes terroristes
donc comme il n'y a pas de profil type
sauf peut-être quelques failles
narcissiques chez elles la prise en
charge en est d'autant plus difficile
puisqu'il faut la mettre en œuvre d'une
façon quasiment personnalisée
donc cette prise en charge elle est
considérable avec énormément d'activités
c'est 18h sur 24 avec un personnel hors
pair et deux écueils
l'observance des activités comme on peut
parler de l'observance du traitement
elles y vont ça c'est sûr mais
parallèlement à ça il y a de petit avoir
une forme d'accoutumance c'est-à-dire
une forme de manipulation à l'envers mon
chers collègues vous parlez de
d'éradicalisation dans ces quartiers on
ne parle pas
d'éradicalisation on parle prise en
charge de la radicalisation de toute
façon des écueils terribles qui
nécessitent énormément de monde de monde
formés et en général le personnel qui
est là et volontaire pour être formé
donc il y a des ces pips encore plus
qu'ailleurs il y a des médiateurs des
faits religieux qui ne sont pas des
aumôniers mais des médiateurs des faits
religieux c'est à dire avec des
formations en histoire en géopolitique
etc donc en fait ma question c'est que
l'observance l'accoutumance le
diagnostic de la Coupe immense
c'est-à-dire de la takia parce que ces
femmes elles vont rester 6 mois puis
encore 6 mois puis peut-être encore six
mois donc ce sont des prises en charge
pardonnez-moi mais il faut parler budget
qui sont coûteuses donc nous avons posé
la question il semblerait que pour
Rennes on est un an de recul mais qu'on
soit déjà peut-être à 60000 euros mais
maxio en fait c'est que tous ces gens
qui se donnent les accompagnants je
dirais qui se donnent pour prendre en
charge ces femmes très difficiles en
fait elles vont pas gagner plus que
quand elles sont dans avec des détenus
de droits communs or c'est
particulièrement d'ici donc je voulais
savoir si dans les budgets s'il pouvait
y avoir pour les accompagnements aussi
une forme de reconnaissance dans cette
prise en charge qui est très longue
difficile et douloureuse
merci Madame merci et puis pour conclure
cette série de 13 questions madame que
Kerman
je ne suis pas Judas
bien très rapidement très rapidement
d'avoir pour appuyer des choses qui ont
été dites précédemment je pense que on a
réellement une question alors un peu en
marge de la question bien évidemment des
femmes et qui est celle effectivement du
rapport et du droit des grands-parents
qui de fait alors une fois qu'on s'est
dit ça mais aujourd'hui et bafoué et je
pense que c'est un vrai sujet tout comme
le sujet
finalement de personnes qui ont quitté
le territoire national enfant et qui
reviennent adultes mais sont-ils
réellement
adultes au-delà de du simple âge puisque
quand il reviennent ils reviennent
finalement dans un pays dont les propres
règles leur ont été entre guillemets
supprimer dans leur conscience sur le
suivi donc de la radicalisation moi
monsieur par des sous je voulais vous
demander c'est comment est-ce qu'à un
moment donné on évalue ce processus de
d'éradicalisation
quoi sans remettre en cause et bien
évidemment je pense qu'il y a des choses
qui relèvent aussi du secret et c'est
bien normal sur ces sujets là mais
voilà quel processus à un moment donné
va pouvoir faire dire par les
représentants de la société que que
peuvent être les juges que le suivi
s'atténue voir s'arrête une fois la
personne sortie de prison et sur sur
cette notamment sur des profils
dont on peut penser que la perversité
est très forte on efface quand même à
des gens qui ont souvent caché le fait
qu'ils allaient partir qui ont su
pendant parfois plusieurs mois voire
plusieurs années développées une dualité
de personnalité et partir du jour au
lendemain on a tous des cas je crois
autour de nous et donc comment est-ce
qu'à un moment donné on est en capacité
d'évaluer que la personne est réellement
des radicalisée ou est-ce qu'elle reste
dans une forme de duplicité alors ça
relève certainement de questions psycho
quoi qui dorent plus psychique que
juridique mais quel contrôle en tout cas
de la société à travers l'institution
judiciaire on a sur ça quelle évaluation
est-ce qu'il y a des rendus voilà je
j'y serai pas plus longue pour la 13ème
merci Madame cuckermann
et bien monsieur le ministre vous avez
la parole
c'est une lourde tâche qui m'inconque
maintenant parce que vous avez été
légitimement très curieux de ces de ces
situations qui bien sûr nous inquiète
infiniment donc
monsieur le sénateur what's the blade et
Monsieur sénateur Denis puisque vous
avez eu la bonne idée de poser
la même question
délai de jugement
[Musique]
c'est la question la plus difficile que
l'on peut naturellement poser puisque il
y a des situations qui sont très simples
et qui vont donner lieu à une réponse
simple instruction rapide
phase de jugement rapide et puis vous
avez
des situations qui vont durer dans le
temps je pense aux situations
complexes factuellement complexe mais
également mettant en cause de nombreux
mises en examen et naturellement ensuite
il faudra dans l'audiancement de
l'affaire prendre considération le
nombre d'accusés si c'est une affaire
criminelle donc je peux pas répondre
évidemment à votre question quand il est
vrai que tout dépend en réalité là on
est vraiment pour le coup sur du cas du
cas par cas une expression qu'on utilise
souvent en la matière mais là en
l'occurrence judiciairement je peux pas
en dire beaucoup plus
vous avez vu que les attentats de 2015
mais il a fallu une très très longue
instruction il a fallu un procès qui est
un procès fleuve le V13 est un procès
fleuve évidemment il y a des situations
où on a deux personnes
selon qu'elles reconnaissent les faits
qu'elle ne reconnaissent pas les faits
qu'on ait les éléments probatoires que
on ne les ai pas que ça suscite des
investigations tout cela
nous amène
vers des règles qui sont différentes
dans chaque affaire
on va ensuite poser une question
complexe si j'ose dire à la fois sur la
façon dont on prend en charge et en même
temps sur
la matière de la déradicalisation
comment on s'y prend pour
d'éradiquer et
cette question elle rejoint au fond la
13e question
est-ce que l'on peut avoir des
certitudes
non
pas plus dans la matière terroriste que
dans le droit commun
vous avez des gens qui font l'objet
d'une remise en liberté ils ont été
suivis des expertises permettent de
penser que plus jamais il n'y aura de
réitération puis malheureusement ça
arrive certains en veulent au juge qui
ont pris la décision d'autres plus sages
pensent que le juge même si il a
beaucoup de qualité n'a pas le don de
médiumeté et que malheureusement des
accidents comme ça ça arrive
alors je vais essayer de vous dire
comment on
d'abord estime les choses
il y a premièrement des quartiers
d'évaluation de la radicalisation
c'est une évaluation approfondie de 15
semaines c'est long 15 semaines
ça permet de regarder d'appréhender de
parler d'échanger de voir le niveau
d'engagement dans la radicalisation
ce sont du personnel pénitentiaires mais
également psychologue psychiatre
éducateur s'épip on est dans
nécessairement du pluridisciplinaire où
l'imaginait bien
à l'issue de cette évaluation il y a
trois options possibles
soit une détention ordinaire
le risque de prosélytisme est faible
soit une orientation en quartier de
prise en charge de la radicalisation
QPR et on a ouvert récemment un quartier
de cette nature à Rennes ça n'existait
pas
là on est en présence
de femmes de femmes à Rennes et d'hommes
dans les dans les quartiers hommes qui
présentent un risque de prosélytisme et
ou de passage à l'acte
identifié
et puis on a la troisième
solution c'est le placement au quartier
d'isolement pour les plus dangereux ou
les plus dangereux
celles qui sont en tous les cas à ce
stade inaccessible
à la déradicalisation
la déradicalisation quelque chose
d'infiniment complexe
mais je voudrais m'arrêter une toute
petite seconde sur les dispositifs des
médiateurs du fer les yeux
en réalité si vous allez voir un
terroriste et que vous lui dites
vous vous êtes fourvoyé le Coran c'est
pas ce que vous en dites la vision vous
avez de la religion et pas la bonne
c'est fini c'est le blocage absolu
ce qu'il faut c'est que il y est la
possibilité d'introduire le doute alors
d'abord il faut que l'interlocuteur en
face
est une connaissance théologique bien
plus importante
que le terroriste ce qui est assez
souvent le cas d'ailleurs parce que ce
sont des gens qui connaissent pas la
religion pour beaucoup d'entre eux
et moi j'avais été très très
impressionné je suis allé au Maroc et
ils ont mis en place un processus de
cette nature et ils ont choisi vraiment
parmi les théologiens qui entraînent en
prison des gens qui étaient
extrêmement pointu dans leur domaine et
ils instillent un doute petit à petit
presque subrepticement qui amène
l'intéresser à se poser un certain
nombre de questions c'est comme ça qu'on
y arrive naturellement il y a pas que ça
il y a pas que ça il y a et moi j'ai
souhaité que l'on ait recours à des
chercheurs en théologie je veux vraiment
du le plus haut niveau possible après
l'impossible nul n'est tenues bon fait
avec les médiateurs du fer religieux que
que nous avons on est choisi en fonction
de la capacité qu'ils ont à retourner
une situation
et puis il y a évidemment psychologue
psychiatre CP là encore on est dans du
pluridisciplinaire et petit à petit on
analyse le désengagement quand il
intervient
voilà un peu les stratégies qui sont
mises en place à vrai dire on n'a pas
tellement d'autres choix et puis il y a
ensuite vous le savez les suivis qui ont
été mises en place à la fois judiciaires
aujourd'hui
juge d'application des peines on a un
suivi judiciaire possible ça n'était pas
le cas autrefois et bien sûr les Mikas
traditionnels le jour on envisage une
une fin de peine qui est qui est proche
j'ajoute évidemment que mais je veux pas
en dire trop sur cette question le
renseignement pénitentiaire est à
l'oeuvre évidemment et que il permet
également d'avoir une vision très
objectivée de du maintien dans
l'engagement ou du désengagement de la
détenus ou du ou du détenu
vous m'avez madame la sénatrice
Carrère posait la question
la prise en charge des mineurs alors
mineurs de retour de zone d'opération
font l'objet d'un suivi individualisé
systématique évidemment très attentif je
voudrais dire d'ailleurs madame la
sénatrice que la PJJ particulièrement
attentive les juges ont aussi une
formation j'y reviendrai dans un instant
vous savez
un certain nombre de psychologues et pas
des moindres on dit en réalité que ces
enfants étaient des bombes à
retardements parce qu'ils ont vu
évidemment des scènes traumatiques qui
peuvent ressurgir il faut vraiment que
nous portions toute notre attention sur
l'évolution qui est la leur et qu'on est
le plus d'assurance possible sachant
bien sûr que
dès la descente d'avion j'ai dit tout à
l'heure les mineurs rapatriés
sont pris en charge par la justice
et juge des enfants mais tout de suite
un dispositif de suivi spécifique qui
est incarné par le prononcé d'une double
mesure c'est un placement dans une
structure ou famille d'accueil de l'aide
sociale à l'enfance et une mesure
éducative confiée à la PJJ à protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse
pour les enfants il est évidemment
primordial de préserver de cultiver
leurs liens de fratrie faire très
attention à ne pas séparer frère et sœur
et l'un d'entre vous m'a posé la
question pardon si je ne suis pas
précisément la chronologie de vos
interventions mais du droit à des
grands-parents il reste naturellement
intact la filiation n'est pas touchée
les grands-parents sont heureux heureux
pour beaucoup d'entre eux de pouvoir
enfin tenter de sortir leurs
petits-enfants de là où ils sont partis
à leur grand désespoir d'ailleurs
puisque ce sont les enfants de ces
personnes qui ont emmené les mômes
là-bas et souvent sans qu'il le sachent
le sénateur vous disiez tout à l'heure
il faut être modeste dans ma commune
mais dans des familles
dans des familles on se rend compte
désespérés que des enfants qu'on croyait
loin de toutes ces choses sont partis
faire le bien et on imagine la
déconvenue le mot est faible des parents
donc les grands-parents ils sont heureux
de récupérer leurs petits-enfants et on
fait attention à tout cela madame stage
Brignon vous m'avez posé la question les
femmes sont systématiquement
judiciarisés des tenues il y en a une là
j'ai pas tous les chiffres parce que
évidemment ce sont des procédures qui
sont en cours mais à ma connaissance il
y a une Fame hospitalisée les autres
sont détenus alors je j'essaierai de
donner le chiffre plus précis mais je ne
peux pas le faire et vous imaginez bien
que le parquet national antiterroriste
ne me communique pas
au jour le jour la façon dont ils gèrent
les affaires dont il a dont il a la
charge
monsieur
le sénateur le rue de lier
jugé sur place pas jugé sur place alors
écoutez
moi je veux rappeler que les victimes
sont là-bas
et qu'il n'y a rien d'anormal à ce que
des ressortissants français soient jugés
sur place
la ligne rouge que l'on essaie de ne pas
dépasser c'est évidemment l'exécution
d'une peine de mort qui se répondent
parce qu'il s'agit qu'on le veuille ou
non on le veuille ou non d'un
ressortissant français
juger sur place ça n'est pas gênant et
d'ailleurs la doctrine c'est de ne
rapatrier que ceux qui veulent
voilà et là dessus je pense que nous
avons raison parce que personne n'oublie
bien sûr que ces gens sont allés nous
combattre d'une certaine façon et que
voilà absolument absolument
et qu'ils ont d'ailleurs généré le
malheur des enfants dont on vient de
parler il y a une seconde et que nous
avons tous à l'esprit ça c'est une
réalité
doctrine française c'est que les adultes
qui ont choisi de rejoindre les rangs
d'une organisation terroriste doivent
être jugés sur place au plus proche des
lieux où ils ont commis l'effet où se
trouve les victimes voilà la doctrine
qui est la nôtre
maintenant
il est difficile d'interdire un
ressortissant français qui veut revenir
sur le sol français c'est difficile de
lui interdire mais encore faut-il que
ces choses soient possibles et notamment
je pense à la sécurité de nos soldats
alors c'est la raison pour laquelle
d'ailleurs
l'arrêt qui a été rendue par la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme ne nous
demande pas de changer de doctrine il
nous demande simplement de mieux
informer et de permettre un recours et
nous allons comme je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure évidemment nous y adapter parce
que nous sommes
respectueux de l'État de droit et nous
sommes bien sûr respectueux des
décisions qui sont rendues par la Cour
européenne
sur les chiffres
bon ça revient très souvent monsieur le
sénateur
on peut pas vous les donner de façon
très précise il y aurait aux alentours
de 200
les enfants c'est encore plus complexe
parce que je l'ai dit tout à l'heure il
y a des enfants qui sont nés sur jaune
et qui n'ont pas d'état civils qui sont
pas répertoriés chez nous
donc c'est extrêmement difficile de
donner les chiffres précis ou my reposer
une question à laquelle par anticipation
il y a une seconde j'ai répondu la
doctrine au fond c'est que on juge sur
place
d'ailleurs dans le droit commun c'est ce
qui se fait si un français va commettre
une infraction à l'étranger qu'il est
appréhendé à l'étranger il est
naturellement jugé à l'étranger
monsieur le sénateur bonne Carrère
je vais vous dire que les cellules
départementales de suivi pour la
prévention de la radicalisation et
l'accompagnement des familles
sont le maillon essentiel du suivi dans
les départements et
naturellement il y a une interaction
mais très très proche
à la fois des
cprf de la protection judiciaire de la
jeunesse des juges des enfants
clairement
on a identifié qu'il était indispensable
que nous intervenions avec humanité pour
ses enfants mais on a aussi estimé qu'il
pouvait constituer un danger et donc il
faut absolument qu'on suive ça de près
il y a pas d'angélisme là vous voyez
de l'humanité sans doute de l'angélisme
certainement pas il faut qu'on soit très
vigilant et on n'est pas dans un
processus de placement classique c'est
une absolue évidence et je souhaite
pouvoir vous rassurer sur ce point
monsieur le sénateur sueur bon pour les
chiffres
je vous ai répondu au fond que je ne
pouvais pas vous répondre de façon très
précise
difficilement ce que ce que je pourrais
ajouter d'autres
je on a une on a une estimation
j'ajoute aussi que pour les
autorisations quand elles sont
présentées on est davantage dans le
périmètre du ministère des Affaires
étrangères que dans le périmètre qui est
le mien on est même totalement dans le
périmètre des Affaires étrangères sur
les questions d'autorisation
oui pardon je peux me permettre sur les
sur les à peu près 200 qui seraient
encore sur place
l'État français les autorités françaises
ont-elles pardon déjà été saisies de
demandes de retour vous savez pas
vous avez vu que on est intervenu non
pas au cas par cas au cas par cas mais
au coup parcours aussi qui a eu
plusieurs phases sur ceux qui ont été
rapatriés on a un certain nombre de
d'épisodes qui sont des épisodes
différents et ça dépend aussi et pour
beaucoup de la sécurité des intervenants
et de nos soldats en particulier ce
n'est pas simple d'approcher ses camps
il y a véritablement du danger donc il
faut le faire avec une extrême prudence
c'est pas j'arrive je frappe à la porte
et je rapatrie tout le monde d'un coup
ça c'est ce qu'on lit dans les gazettes
de la part de certains qui pensent que
nous ne sommes pas assez vigilants à la
situation des femmes et des enfants mais
la réalité c'est pas celle-là voilà et
il faut naturellement préserver pour
imaginer la sécurité de de des
différentes les opérations
sur le droit des grands-parents monsieur
monsieur Loïc Hervé m'a posé la question
j'ai déjà répondu il reste évidemment
intact filiation et également une autre
question intéressante sur la coopération
européenne évidemment que nous
échangeons avec les Européens les Belges
en particulier les Néerlandais les
Allemands les Danois ont rapatriés
certains de leurs ressortissants
bon ces décisions restent de la
compétence nationale c'est une évidence
pour tout le monde et
je pense que le dispositif français qui
est à la fois judiciaire administratif
sans doute le plus complet ce qui nous
empêche pas évidemment dans nos dans nos
dans nos relations d'échanger sur les
pratiques des uns et des autres madame
la sénatrice
melitive vous m'avez posé la question
sur la rage n'en fais pas la même tout à
fait la même lecture que vous
on va adapter bien sûr ce que la reine
nous demande d'adapter
il n'y a pas de demande d'autorisation
judiciaire je vous ai entendu dire ça
tout à l'heure moins que je n'ai pas été
attentif ce qui m'arrive hélas parfois
mais voilà il nous faut répondre bien
sûr et pour le reste l'arrêt rappel
c'est quand même extrêmement important
que
[Musique]
aucune obligation de droite
internationale conventionnelle ou
coutumier ne contraint les états
rapatrier leur ressortissants
voilà mais se pose alors la question du
droit du ressortissant s'il demande à
rentrer et là c'est un peu différent et
il faut que l'on motive les refus et que
on permette un recours si j'ai bien lu
la décision madame l'herbier
préoccupation évidemment légitime de la
compétence de tous ceux qui vont avoir
en charge
ces enfants parce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure c'est c'est
à la fois indispensable que nous le
fassions
dans nos valeurs universelles nous nous
portons la protection des enfants bien
sûr mais également il nous faut une
vigilance particulière en la matière les
magistrats sont confrontés depuis bien
des années assez phénomènes
des spécifications et les stages
spécifiques sont dispensés par l'École
nationale de la magistrature
ce qui répond très précisément
pardonnez-moi à votre question des liens
évidemment très réguliers des échanges
établis avec les services du parquet
national antiterroriste
et les juges des enfants qui
viennent sur ce domaine particulier ce
spécialiste et s'organise bien sûr parce
que vous l'avez noté et vous n'avez pas
tort il y a une spécificité dans le
traitement judiciaire bien sûr que l'on
réserve à cet enfant à ses enfants
pardonnez-moi enfin Madame madame Kerman
et et Madame Mercier madame cuckermann
comment on évalue le processus de
radicalisation bon je vous ai prévenu
j'aimerais tellement pouvoir vous dire
qu'on est sur du 100% bon
non non mais c'est un petit clin d'oeil
amical que je vous adresse
c'est le problème évidemment de toute
œuvre de toute œuvre judiciaire de toute
œuvre humaine tout simplement on fait
tout pour et ça marche parfois et ça
marche souvent et c'est la même chose
qu'en matière de récidive en droit
commun
beaucoup de gens qui ne récidivent pas
on en parle d'ailleurs jamais n'a jamais
lu une gazette qui titres monsieur
duchemol n'a pas récidivé en mange si
par malheur pour notre société et pour
une nouvelle victime et la récidivé on
en parle bien sûr voilà ce que ce que ce
que je peux vous dire enfin
deux mots sur Rennes et sur son budget
de fonctionnement bon Rennes en a suivi
pas à pas la Chancellerie la création de
ce quartier avec une directrice qui est
formidable et oui il faut lui rendre il
faut lui rendre hommage formidable très
investi
une envie de faire les choses d'ailleurs
c'était déjà un modèle en termes de de
travail des détenus puisque à Rennes on
fabrique des uniformes pour les agents
pénitentiaires bon il y a des tas
d'ateliers vraiment c'est c'est quelque
chose de dynamique de bienfaits alors
sur le budget de fonctionnement pour les
quartiers de prise en charge Rennes
c'est 20000 euros 2021 c'est porté 60000
en 2022 voilà et puis ce quartier assez
place il va être porté à 29 places
et son mobilisés et formés 12
surveillants trois gradés un directeur
un directeur d'insertion de probation de
psychologues et deux éducateurs
voilà madame la sénatrice
merci monsieur le ministre pour avoir
répondu à l'ensemble de ces questions je
crois de façon très
très claire très précise dans tous les
cas pour ce que l'on peut dire
constance il me reste à lever la réunion
de commission et à vous souhaiter à
toutes et à tous une excellente soirée
merci